[Applause]
the last 24 hours
those have kind of been the easier ones
because I felt already going into the
tiebreaks that I had a very good chance
I was calm I was confident so this
really wasn't like the difficult part
yesterday I mean was just a lot of fun
and I think a great chest show I think I
did a lot of things right in this in
this match in terms of general strategy
and openings and search but and I mean
to some extent my failures early in the
match to to win very good positions is
you know I statistics or incidence but
when it happens over over again of
course there's something something wrong
so usually I should I should have been
up plus 1 or plus 2 early on and then
then it's a whole different whole
different ballgame but yeah when he
managed to hold those positions earlier
I don't know maybe uh maybe I should
have been more focused on that in my
preparation to UM to train for the for
the fifth and six even seventh hours of
play because I felt that it was very
clear that I was better than him in in
the second and third hours to play a lot
better but then he started to defend and
he became difficult yeah I mean in some
games I made blunders that I don't
usually make but I don't think there was
anything like to too unusual and game
eight well I both came seven and eight
Swarek really just awful and in game
eight I made a gamble at some point
which
just happened they often of course the
move I missed in in the fifth game was a
contributing factor to to to me playing
you know playing poorly making a blunder
in that game with it I don't think it
affected me later on and that's for game
8 ok it's not it's not my proudest
moment but I just I was just devastated
I couldn't I couldn't sit there
yeah when everything is under control
it's very very difficult to beat me but
obviously my my playing strength drops
quite quite a bit when when you know
everything is not going according to
plan so I think maybe I'll have to have
to work on that more seriously in the
future since I mean it's very easy when
things are things are going my way I'm
going from victory in one tournament to
another and the confidence is there but
when it's not there things fall apart a
bit so it's something I'll have to think
about the Merkur in general after game
10 when I won I've slept very well and
it was a little bit more difficult to
fall asleep yesterday since I was still
very excited yeah no no I mean after
after the eighth game and the ninth game
wasn't so easy but after the 10 I've
slept like a baby
yes certainly after game 8 I was I did
not have a positive state of mind I am I
felt that even though I I still thought
I was the strongest player that it would
be very difficult to prove since after
all I had only a couple of
chances chances left to win games so
yeah at that point I I mean I guess a
part of me still believed in it but but
it was very ready even before the tenth
game I was not in a great state of mind
but I managed to at least perform more
or less sensibly in that game of course
at some point yeah i blundered he could
have forced the draw and then thinking
why not
left again but then so I was trying to
debate at that point wherever I was
going to play the sort of position with
two knights against the rook but I felt
that there were absolutely no chances
there's I thought yeah okay now we go
home now we go home and this is this now
I'll have to win the black in the
eleventh game and then okay did
something else in the game started it's
been a fight throughout it hasn't been
particularly pretty of course the finish
was was pretty at least from from my
point of view but uh it's most of all
been a fight and I mean for me that that
is what was justice about and I think
what this much it should be about so in
that sense it's been expensive